jérôme marty président de l'union
française pour la vie de scène libre
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france
d'abord ce cette prolongation du
confinement jusqu'au 11 mai c'est une
décision de bon sens selon vous c'est
une décision de bon sens oui c'est ce
que les soignants attendez on passait
même que ce serait prolongée encore sans
doute encore un peu plus puisque on voit
bien que aujourd'hui nous ne sommes
toujours pas en capacité de protéger la
population de donner les masques et ce
sont maintenant des masques alternatif
il ya quantité d'entreprises qui s'y
sont mis et qu'ils produisent
on n'est pas en capacité non plus de
tester suffisamment que ce soit les
tests sérologiques de pouvoir quelques
quelques années la population qui a déjà
développé la maladie et qui est
maintenant immunisée ou des tests de
type rt pcr c'est à dire ces fameux
bécaud vionnaz zoo qui permettent de
savoir qui est en train de développer la
maladie à l'instant t
et qui est vecteur du virus on n'a pas
ces éléments là et donc le déconfinement
alors qu'on n'a pas ces éléments là et
toujours un petit peu dangereux on
espère que le moi de le mois à venir
sera mis à profit pour développer à la
fois les tests et développer les moyens
de protection pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'est pas en capacité aujourd'hui de
tester massivement les français pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas de masque
aujourd'hui accessible pour l'ensemble
de la population c'est cela que on
voudrait comprendre et c'est ce qu'on
aurait voulu entendre de la part du
président de la république et asseoir
aussi il ya manifestement eu un problème
de préparation il ya eu manifestement
des retards qui ont été pris avec
un manque de signalements à la
population qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
soignant que la population en général
qui était ce fameux aveux et qui était
le fait de dire on a l'on découvre une
situation catastrophique on manque de
tout on n'a pas de masque on n'a pas de
capacités de test il va falloir qu'on
produise et là on a vu que les autant
les soignants d'ailleurs que la
population les entreprises et
collectivités locales une fois que cela
était connu
tout le monde s'est retroussé les
manches et tout le monde a produit en
quelque sorte un chemin dans cette
administration française qui est
extrêmement lourde qui nous a beaucoup
ralenti et qui a fait la preuve de son
échec
alors on en est là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les choses semblent avancer
un petit peu plus sans doute encore
quand même trop lentement
des décisions ont été prises mais des
décisions sont peu compréhensibles pour
nous comme celle par exemple de tester
uniquement les gens est symptomatique ou
comme celle de dire que l'on va rendre
obligatoire le port du masque mais
seulement à partir du 11 mai alors que
l'on sait que les gens se déplacent
aujourd'hui en transports en commun pour
aller travailler que certaines
entreprises ont repris et il faut
impérativement que dans ces moments là
la population puisse se masquer est ce
qu'on sera réellement capacité de tester
les personnes qui présentent des
symptômes l'ensemble de ces personnes
à partir du 11 mai alors les populations
qu'ils les personnes qui présentent des
symptômes probablement oui ce que l'on
voudrait c'est conteste aussi les
personnes qui ont le plus d'interactions
sociétale et c'est à dire les personnes
qui rencontrent le plus de monde au
cours de leur activité professionnelle
les jeunes notamment ceux là doivent
être testés régulièrement parce qu'on
sait que cette maladie est sournoise
qu'on sait qu'elle revêt de nombreuses
formes asymptomatiques ou très peu
symptomatiques et qu'elle victoris
pendant sept ans elle se développe et
l'épidémie continue à se développer
c'est ce qui explique le fait que ce
soit en plateau et non par descente de
courbes rapides sûres notamment sur le
cluster de l'île de france parce que les
gens se contaminent dans les transports
en commun ils se contaminent dans les
entreprises et puis il se contaminent
dans la cellule familiale
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
contaminait qui rentre à la cellule
comme ils n'ont pas de masque et comme
souvent ils vivent
des dindes et des petits appartements et
nombreux mais à ce moment là c'est
l'ensemble de la famille est contaminée
et on a un plateau plutôt qu'avoir une
descente de courbes justement sur la
date du 11 mai c'est à partir de là
qu'il doit y avoir normalement
déconfinement progressif penser que ce
délai il va il sera possible je sais pas
trop flotté j'espère j'espère que que
d'une part que le confinement va être
respectées dit si heureuse b mais on
voit bien qu'il y avait des confirmands
officiel une déconfinement officieux
puisque on voit que de nombreuses
entreprises qui ne sont pas directement
indispensable confinement ont repris et
elles ont repris alors même que
notamment les sous-traitants nombre de
nombreux sous-traitants ne sont pas en
capacité totale à offrir la protection
globale de leurs salariés
ce n'est pas leur faute est un problème
structurel mais elle attend dans
l'épidémie se développe donc ce qu'on
espère c'est que les choses vont enfin
accélérer quand on fait les mots seront
suivis d'actes parce que on nous a
tellement dit des choses sans que nous
soignants nous voyons les prémices d'une
concrétisation je vous rappelle que en
ville notamment et dans certains
hôpitaux aussi on est toujours en
attente de moyens de protection digne de
ce nom
si on leur trouvera progressif des à
l'école et dans les crèches voudrais
vous entendre là dessus jean michel
blanc car il a parlé 1 ce matin d'un
retour qui ne serait pas obligatoire
quels sont les risques pour les élèves
des les risques vous savez il faut ce
qu'il faut regarder c'est pas seulement
la classe c'est d'abord le moyen de
transport pour se rendre à l'école
c'est donc le bourg c'est la cantine ou
la façon de prendre le repas
et puis le retour au domicile poussent à
fuir décroisée de population tout ça
fait des risques potentiels si on n'est
pas en capacité de couvrir de respecter
la distanciation et puis le donner les
moyens pour que les enfants ne s'infecte
bas et vous savez combien il est
difficile chez des enfants notamment les
plus jeunes de faire respecter le port
de masques par exemple de faire
respecter la distance entre les élèves
et c'était le président
agron lui-même qui justifient au tout
début de la crise
la fermeture des écoles part cela par le
fait qu'on ne pouvait pas assurer le
respect des distances et des distances
et le respect des mesures barrières chez
des jeunes enfants notamment avec la
problématique des cours de récréation et
c'est le risque c'est que avec un air 0
qui est de 2,7 même si le sait
maintenant que les enfants sont plutôt
moins vecteurs que le reste de la
population contrairement à ce qui peut
être dit au début même s'ils sont moins
vecteur ils peuvent quand même contaminé
au sein d'une classe contact proche et
prolongé on le répète et à ce moment là
ils peuvent ramener l'infection au
domicile et au dos messieurs on peut
très bien avoir des parents ou des
grands-parents qui présentent des
facteurs de risque de développement de
symptômes graves de la maladie
donc tous ces problèmes là font qu' il
va y avoir une heure une organisation
qui doit être mise en place au cours du
mois et il est probable que les
syndicats l'éducation nationale aux
côtés des soignants devront se
rencontrer pour pour proposer des
solutions
une dernière question vous parlez d'un
du plateau puisque l'épidémie semble
s'accélérer ça veut dire qu'on est très
proche du pic vous croyez que ce pic on
peut le prévoir pour quand non c'est
picon lapasset si vous voulez on était
même plateau qui est très élevé qui mes
intentions
les services hospitaliers et la médecine
de ville en particulier en ile-de-france
et dans l'est mais on pouvait s'attendre
à ce qu'il y ait une redescente assez
rapide et en fait on est sur une une
ligne droite un plateau qui redescend
très lentement et ce plateau peut
s'expliquer par le fait que justement on
continue à aller travailler pour une
grande brune un nombre non négligeable
de parisienne par exemple continuer à
aller travailler continue à se déplacer
dans les transports en commun alors même
qu'on a diminué le nombre de rames de
métro donc on a concentré la population
dans des petits espaces et la population
aujourd'hui n'est pas totalité masqué on
n'a pas les moyens de donner
la protection à toute la population et
autres l'épidémie continue comme ça
tranquillement à évoluer ce qu'il faut
colonne et c'est que l'on puisse d'une
part testé beaucoup écarté chaque fois
qu on trouve quelques heures de
contaminer le en quelque sorte que le
confiner dans un lieu séparé confine
également de façon à séparer les sujets
contacts et puis donné à tout le monde
de la capacité à porter des masques
et ce n'est pas encore le cas
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup jérôme marty
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous êtes le président de l'union
française pour la médecine libre merci à
vous